I haven't won an Emmy I believe in nine
years so it is special for that reason
the reception I got from the audience
was extremely special very touching
we all know what's going on in my life
and I alluded to that in my remarks and
I've been very blessed to discover how
many people our show has influenced in
their lives and because of that because
of the power of our show Jeopardy how I
have become a factor in the lives of so
many other people in that I'm in your
home every day and I have been for the
past 35 years longer than that if you
count some of my other shows but
jeopardy has become a special
institution in Americana and it has been
a force for good a force for knowledge a
force for the best kind of reality
television really when you think about
it anybody can succeed anybody can win a
lot of money just ask James holtzhauer
and so hmm
he's been a lot of fun to watch yes
indeed he has seemingly no weaknesses
there are no areas in which he cannot do
well he has missed only one final
jeopardy since he came on the program
and he's coming back in two weeks right
after the teachers tournament so you're
gonna get to enjoy James and Alex for a
while longer how about that folks
so yeah this this has been a special
year for Jeopardy and certainly a very
special and in many ways rewarding year
for me to discover how loved I am all
across America has well does it touch me
so thank you I don't have the energy
that I used to have but you're supposed
to give me the answer no that makes for
a very difficult interview but believe
me interviewers have tried that in the
past and they died after a few seconds
yes young lady
[Music]
if there's a message that I can put out
there it is as I discovered yesterday at
the pan cam can walk is that there's
hope I ran into pancreas pancreatic
cancer survivors who have survived for
22 years 14 years 12 years 15 years so
there is hope and as dr. oz mentioned to
me while we were sitting during a
commercial break earlier this evening
he said you know Alex if you had
developed pancreatic cancer maybe 10 or
15 years ago it would be a lot rougher
on you but so many more new medications
are available to sufferers so many new
techniques so many new ways of dealing
with the mutations of the cancer genes
he said your if you're gonna get
something bad like this you got it at a
good time so yeah that's the message I
would send to all people out there and
there and they're better halves the
people who look after them the
caretakers who have such a difficult
difficult chore okay thank you all guys